[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting
i'm talking about i'm just gonna give
you a little bit of update on my
spiritual journey
my spiritual walk how's my walk how's
your walk well i read my bible last
night you know it's just that's the
thing we used to ask people it's like
that was kind of the shorthand
when we were in
evangelicalism being like
how'd you walk
how's your walk
i never asked anybody that with that
how's your look on my face or the accent
or or it would be like
um
how's your quiet time
well like i told you i read my bible
last night actually i got like three
pages into the introduction
of the study bible and fell asleep
the introduction is not a part of the
bible well it is this body it's the
study part it's not the bible no no i
was actually looking at the back i was i
was reading the the selling points of
the of the bible
uh
and it was it said 60 bible 40 notes i
said okay that's a good breakdown 60 40.
yeah
so you you fell asleep
in the intro
that's a good that's a pretty sick intro
just leave it at that man that's why i
think i can get three or four pages
tonight
uh there's 2 500 pages do the math on
that
i've been reading for a thousand years
it's so interesting that like a few
years i i think here's here's one of the
things that's going to come clear over
the course of me kind of giving the
one-year update
of
my
quest to spirituality well one year from
the last time i did it annual
is that you know you make that joke
and you're you're able to laugh at the
fact that like hey yeah you know i'll
take you know me i'll just take if i do
it a couple of pages of the night i'll
i'll make progress
and the way that i would interact with
that and like
i don't know it's like i tense up inside
and i'm like
um
i have could you turn it into an
obligation
yeah we can explore it more but i'm just
kind of
laying it out there at this point that
yeah it's um
it's
laying out another
plan
or system or
idea
against which to measure myself
and
beat myself up to fall short it's it's a
tendency that i have that i'm that
i i described when i
originally when i went back and looked
at my journals like for the for the
first time we talked about our spiritual
deconstruction and i have my episode i
you know i'm reminded of
reading my college journals and
just
how
i just felt sorry for that guy
because he was just constantly beating
himself up
and
this is something that i'm still coming
to grips with
i'll come back to it but um
the place i want to start is this past
weekend just to kind of
give an update which is
in some ways related but some ways just
uh
you know a nice story that i want to
tell you
you know this
you had plans this weekend you were
doing some you were you were going out
of town and i'm like well damn i'm going
to make some plans too
it's like okay you should see how it
works it's gonna be going friday you're
gonna be gone um
monday so i'm like oh this
this is a great opportunity for me and i
realized well in advance that it was
over
the
valentine weekend
and i was like this is actually clicking
into place because
you know lily and i have this tradition
every year
to
go out i take her out on a valentine's
date
and one of the things i was thinking in
terms of
her being off at college her being a
freshman is that this will be the first
year that
we won't be in the same place we're not
going to have the opportunity to
to to keep our tradition alive
unless
i
i
drive and surprise her
and now that i have some extra time in
this long weekend i was able to do that
and um at first christy was like
well she should we all go and surprise
her she's talking about us coming up
there and seeing her i'm like no
it kind of needs to be this is my thing
you know important milk this is this
important milk this is like pouring milk
oh yeah it's my thing
well yeah it's our date so like if we
all surprised her even if i just went on
a date with her
honestly the other thing i was thinking
was
this will be like a mini
um
solo trip for me
you know i'll be on the road a lot
and then i decided i'm gonna rent a
sprinter van
yeah baby get back in that sprinter van
i'm gonna be camping i don't know where
i'm gonna end up every night i'm just uh
you know i'm just a rambler
i'm just a rolling stone
and i just love the idea of it so i was
like hankering to hit the road like all
those country songs when it's like well
don't plan on me being around for long
because because i gotta i gotta wrap
everything up in my bandana and get back
on the road that's not that's not really
yeah
which is a little antithetical to your
personality it's like i'm really ready
to get home and settle in
yeah yeah well that's the thing about
the van is that every you take
everything with you and no matter where
you go you got everything that you
decided that you need oh yeah including
your high
uh priced blender and all your smoothie
ingredients
oh you can just hook up a regular
blender and because it has regular power
yeah man it's got an inverter it's got
solar panels it's got ac if you need it
it's got heat if you need it so you made
a smoothie every morning or with a
toilet in it you could take a dump while
taking a shower in the exact same place
i didn't do that
uh
but you had a smoothie every every day
um
i skipped one day
it's good to give your body a break
anyway
i thought it would be
like a nice
mini solo trip too you know this podcast
was coming up
it would give me some more time for
reflection
and uh processing
i'm like well i know i'm a verbal
processor so i'm i might be talking out
loud to myself but no one will know
people driving by on the freeway will
think that i'm on a call
if it comes to it
i um
so
i pl the
the surprise for lily was
christy ended up talking to her about
how she was
shipping something to her dorm room so
she needed to be there
on saturday
we didn't know exactly what was going to
show up so she was basically like trying
to say
don't make plans because there's
something here and then i when i talked
to her i was like you know
we have this tradition we're going to
have to do it virtual this year and
mom's shipping something that you go
once you get that then we're going to do
our
i have an idea we're going to do a
virtual game a lie it was a lie oh wow
it was me
that was showing up i was the package
okay well
um a little deceptive
well yeah i mean it's you can lie for a
surprise
yeah i agree with that you and your
are you a bible thumper now yeah yeah
i've been reading i read three and a
half pages of the bible yeah last night
and i gotta say
lying's an issue with me now
the truth is very important to me
yes i know rhett
you and your truth
um
i'm a big fan of meaning though maybe
i'll get back to that talk
um so actually i got there friday night
she got out of a class and then
i called her and i i was parked in her
parking lot
but i had a backdrop that looked
like she couldn't tell what it was and i
started talking to her you green trained
it i didn't green screen it no i was
like i was against like a white building
but it was just white you couldn't tell
well did you say where are you
i said that i was just getting out
i was just getting out of a meeting in
my car so i was as she could tell i was
outdoors in like a parking lot okay i
couldn't hide that and i didn't want to
show a sprinter van
and uh but i was asking her about her
exam and i was like listen have you ever
gotten a package because you know mom
told you the package is coming tomorrow
and i start walking up there and she's
like well typically it comes to the
mailbox but mom's saying that they're
going to deliver it to the dorm and i'm
like yeah i think it's going to show up
somewhere
around here and i turned around and i
showed the sign to her dorm
and she freaked out and then uh she came
outside and i
i facetimed christy so she we could like
be feel like she was a part of it
because i felt bad leaving christy
behind and and lily came out and she was
happy to see me she's not a big hugger
uh but i got a big hug it was nice
so we went out went out to dinner that
night actually she had already eaten
this is what i do with the women in my
life yeah right i don't tell them that
it's a date and then they've already
eaten dinner yep it's a tradition so i
just ate some tacos while she watched me
and then
uh the next day was when we had
reservations at one of her favorite
restaurants had it had a good time um
and then she had some school work to do
i you just i didn't let him just stayed
in the van i did a little mountain
biking my dad's living in a van right
now yeah
i thought i was like he's somewhere off
he's somewhere on campus in a van right
now i did not park on campus but i did
tell her i was like you know it's kind
of like
um
if me and your mom got divorced and this
is how what it would feel like for like
when we ate the tacos i brought him back
to the van i'm like eating in the van
and she's watching me
and i'm like if we get if we got
divorced we're not gonna get divorced
everything's going great don't worry
about us
but if we did this is what it would feel
like for you
i went in the van i would just be living
in a van yeah it would be immaculate
though you would have everything that
i need i think
at least i don't know i can do it for a
long weekend
and i could have done it for a few more
days but i don't know if i could
actually live in a van and i definitely
know that i couldn't be divorced
like i'm not okay i'm not i'm not up for
that
and we were having like a really good
conversation
and that first night and like there's
something about
you know you can only connect so much
over
uh
facetime or a phone call you know again
but like in person it was we had a
really good conversation
and
i
all of a sudden and like at a very
poignant point in the conversation
between eating tacos and
talking maybe shedding a tear um
i heard this voice say
well it's not every day that you see
link kneels
parked out front of your house
and it was a dude standing right outside
of the van
a fan
a mythical beast you were just parked on
the street i was parked on the street
yeah near the taco place oh
there weren't no seats so i was like hey
we don't need seats i have a van
that was kind of the thing i kept saying
i have yeah
the door was not open the window was
just kind of
cracked a little bit but so he was
looking through an almost closed window
yelling at me
at well it's not every day you see link
neal in a van in front of your house
and i was like it's worth talking about
i was like hey how you doing he was like
i just i'm just blown away
you mind if i get a picture of your van
and i'm like
it's not you know it's it's actually not
a good time
i gave him that it's not a good time
with your family well i'm literally in
my house i mean it's like hey dude
dude i'm divorced
i live in this van i'm talking to my
daughter who i rarely get to see
and we're having a conversation and this
is my house and you're on the outside of
it you've just walked up to my house
seen me through my window
and just started like how did he respond
yelling at me too when i told him that's
not a good time he said you're right oh
okay i did not say any of that to him
when i said it's not a good time he was
like okay yeah okay not a problem but
like it kind of dawned on him it might
not be a good time yeah
and then he he he left
i don't feel bad about it
no it wasn't it wasn't a good thing
this is my home if the
you know if your
your van is your
is my sanctum well you're about to get
out of your van
i started pulling the shades after that
if i was if the door was open if i was
on the outside of the van that's
different etiquette hashtag van life
come on get on the get on board here
so i'm driving back
uh
and
well first of all i was just reflecting
on the fact that like i was just so
grateful
that
i followed through on the tradition we
had such a good time like
two days and three nights hanging
hanging out on and off together
it was
it was awesome and you know i texted
lily and i was like
you know what i really i really had a
great time
uh i'm glad we got to keep the tradition
going it's not
there's not i don't think there's a lot
of dads who can
spend an entire weekend with their
daughter and they both enjoy it
like we did
and so i'm really grateful for that and
i'm grateful for the for the
relationship that we have
and she wrote back and said you know
that she said she loved me and said she
was so great that i kept the tradition
going and so it was she didn't say you
know on reflection it wasn't a good time
yeah
yeah it was um so
it was a special weekend and that was
the that was the main reason
for going you know to spend time with
her to surprise her but you know every
night i would go into the into the woods
or find a place
to
to set up my van
it's very easy to do you just park it
and this is literally the same exact van
that you were driving on our trip that
where there was valley power steering
issue in death valley yep so that had
the recall has been taken care of they
fixed everything the clamp is on the
power steering and they didn't blame me
they let me run it again
good
um
but i did have
some time
every night you know when i was just by
myself camping and then on the drive
back off there and back just reflecting
did you have fire um
you know what i ended up i had that like
propane fire
ring
uh
which i think would have been okay but i
i never even pulled it out
it was a full moon
i had some music i had a full moon
it worked out was it cold
it wasn't cold
it was like in the 60s i mean it's been
unusually hot you know so
or at that time frame so it was it was
actually perfect
um
but
i downloaded a few books um
uh i actually asked my therapist to
recommend um a couple of books
based on where our conversation is going
i'll come back to talking about my
therapist
because that's kind of wrapped up in
this update for me but um
i started i was listening on the way
there and
uh on the way back i was like
putting the book back on i was gonna do
some more listening and then i was like
you know what
i'm just gonna be quiet
and i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna reflect and you know the
thing that came to me
and i don't know this may not seem
revolutionary
or groundbreaking
um
but
at the moment that i thought it
it felt like it was
it's just not going to sound like it is
and the realization was
you know what
i'm happy
i'm happy
period
period
i think that
uh
the reason why it feels it felt so good
for me to say that is because
i mean first of all it's nice to realize
that you're happy especially when
you have perfectionist
i was going to say perfectionist
tendencies but it goes deeper than that
and when you've got a really
pronounced inner critic
that is constantly talking in your ear
you start to believe
and realize that and realize that maybe
i've believed for
most of my entire life that
i'm not good enough
that
there's always something that could be
improved there's always a way that
something could be better
and
ultimately i think it's
it
for me at least it got it's always gone
back to
looking inward so applying that
uh
brutal level of criticism to myself
so for me to be able to say
you know what
i'm happy
and
also to pair with that
i
i'm i'm still a good person
is
was kind of a powerful moment for me i i
felt like and you know as i said still a
good person because
i think in light of preparing for this
episode
more than normal i was actively thinking
about my past
and my
my devotion to
the
evangelical jesus
um
and how
well i realized that i'm still
currently
in the process of deconstructing
beliefs that have
that i just thought were who i am but
their beliefs that from a very early age
i adopted
um
i you know as as you said in the last
episode by the time you
um
told your deconstruction story you had
deconv it had been many years since you
deconverted
it hadn't been as many for me but that
it had still been years so it was it was
an announcement of something that had
was a long time coming and it already
happened
um
so that's also true of me that like i
you know i deconverted i'm
stopped calling myself a christian
uh
before
the the big podcast announcement
but i'm realizing that the work that i'm
still very much in the midst of is still
a deconstruction for me
um
but being able to say
i
i am happy and that
and i think this is probably an echo of
what i said last year but i think it's a
continuation of that to say that
um
i'm
i'm happy and i'm
i'm on the path i'm i'm happy with the
path that i'm on
and you know what i'm going to do
i'm going to put on some 80s country and
that's what i'm going to listen to
the whole drive back and that's what i
did and you know what i was i was happy
i was happy the whole time because i
felt like
a lot of
even well the trepidation that i
identified within myself that i bring to
this episode is that like as if i
want to
prove something to somebody or that i
owe a continued explanation
to someone who out there who might be
listening to say
um
and for me it would be it it wouldn't be
to convince somebody of something it
would
for themselves it would be to shape
their opinion of me right or
actually
also to shape my opinion of myself to
prove to myself
that i am still
on a good path
that um any doubts that i would have in
my mind that like
i'm still
that i'm actually in this place because
of selfish decisions i've made
like what you talked about last week
like a lot of that
the undermining of
um and
just kind of the
sweeping away like the
with blanket statements and um
just uh
simple explanations of spiritual
deconstruction to say well it's really
your fault it's really on you you're not
doing something right
um i think that
because of the tenets those
perfectionists and
critical self-critical tendencies i'm
susceptible
to to that
um
but i'm also aware of it and i'm
i'm still learning about it so that's
why when me making an active decision to
say
you know what
i don't have to figure out exactly what
i want to say here for anybody else
this is
so for me this is very much an approach
of
i'm just talking to you in the way that
i would if we weren't recording this
like every other podcast because
um
this is a
this is a helpful exercise for me
um but it's not for anybody else and
it's not to prove something to myself
either
so the decision to just listen to some
80s country music was
was was an exercise in freedom for me to
say i'm
i'm not gonna do something because i
feel like i ought to
i'm going to
do something because i want to that is
there's nothing wrong with listen
enjoying music it's like
i would get in a place
where i would feel guilty for like well
you you thought you were going to take
this time
to read this book
or to listen to this book so that you
could gain more insight and that you
could have you could make spiritual
progress
even if you didn't want to share it with
anybody
so like you're you're kind of failing on
your commitment to yourself it's like i
can
very easily get in that headspace again
because
i live there so much
so
actually the spiritual exercise for me
was listening to randy travis well it's
pretty damn spiritual and it's well it's
so good i didn't listen to any of his
gospel songs so it was but yeah it's
opening up my definition of
spirituality and i think
i yes i think it's kind of it's kind of
a joke to say that listening to randy
travis is a spiritual exercise
um
but
i do think
legitimately it is a it is a step a step
in my gr personal growth and
self-acceptance self-compassion
so that
that positions me for more growth in in
every way including spiritually down the
road to come to grips with these things
that i'm talking about
you know
one of the things i was actually talking
about
talking with my brother about this
because i was while you were there i was
in north carolina
and
the
the idea
that
because i was telling them about this
you know about the book the before you
lose your faith yeah and uh constructing
doubt in the church and there is this um
you know
in the evangelical church
and really in sort of
traditional christianity just like an
orthodox christianity
worldview
there is an idea that you can't trust
yourself right that you are you're
fallen
you're sinful and your instincts are
ultimately bad because you you're
corrupted because of original sin
and the only way to have sort of pure
desires and
you got to get that from the holy spirit
you got to get that from god right and
so and that's the that's the way of
thinking that we were
marinated in yeah um
and i and so i see a lot of that in this
book as it talks about like when you
start following your instincts
that's that is perceived as a bad thing
by a lot of christians because they're
like yo well your instincts are going to
be misguided like your understanding is
always going to fall short it's god's
understanding and god's insight that you
have to kind of lean on
and it kind of hit me
because one of the biggest things that
has happened
post deconstruction
is learning to trust my own intuition
it's something my wife talks about a lot
is which is even more difficult for a
woman who is brought up
as someone who's supposed to be
submissive to the man in her life right
so not only can you not trust yourself
but you got to trust the man in your
life and you got to trust god before you
trust yourself
and
you lose the ability a lot of times you
you come out of that and you have the
inability to decipher between desire
and intuition and
this is relevant to what you're saying
yeah yeah because
you know
the you act most people who have an
intact moral compass which i believe is
the vast majority of people there are
people who have certain things whether
it's environmental or genetic that maybe
they're just kind of bad eggs
right and they're gonna like grow up and
be serial killers or whatever
but most people
know what's right and wrong
in a general sense and that doesn't so
that doesn't mean you just follow your
desires because if my desire is to do
something hurtful to you or to my wife
or my kids or whatever
uh or to do something that would be
hurtful to the people in my life
i might still desire to do it but my
intuition
99
of the time tells me well you know that
would be wrong that would be a selfish
decision
you can actually trust that intuition
right so when you talk
we're talking about the definition of
spirituality being much more broad than
we ever understood it to be so when you
talk about listening to randy travis
making the decision to listen to randy
travis or
not listen listening to a book that
would be quote unquote spiritual in the
traditional sense
i think that both of us and lots of
deconstructing christians are learning
to trust your own intuition and be
believing that you actually do know
what's best for yourself
in a given moment so because as it
relates to
you know i'm taking a different
path right now right like i mean yes i
love randy travis and i can see how
listening to him would be a spiritual
exercise
but this i this morning i yeah i'm
working out my wife comes down to the
garage and i'm listening to figuring you
know uh
maria popova's very long book and it's
like she's talking about some esoteric
thing where i'm sitting there like doing
shoulder exercises and jesse just laughs
out loud she's like i don't understand
because she because when jessie comes in
the in the in the gym she wants to turn
on lizzo or whatever and like get popped
oh yeah she's like how do you not get
pumped up i was like because that's not
how i get pumped up it's like i
i don't do this i'm not reading the
bible to please someone else i'm not
reading the bible because there's some
obligation like i'm reading the bible
because i'm interested in it and i'm
following my intuition towards the thing
and when you've made a decision to
listen to randy travis you're doing the
same thing just because it's a different
application or a different path doesn't
make it less spiritual
right the old you
thinks that it's less spiritual and that
because you can hear that voice and that
per that voice is still there let me let
me illustrate in a couple of ways um
i want it since we were shouted out in
the opening of the introduction of
before you lose your faith i did want to
read some of it and i went through the
table of contents
to see what i should read because i
didn't think i was going to read the
whole thing
and i skipped all the way through part
one part two i get to like the very end
and there was a chapter called
the next to last chapter is called
sometimes people don't believe
and i'm like oh okay
this one's about me
this one's about me now so i'm going to
read this one
so i'm going to skip all the way to the
end
and i started reading uh
jared wilson's essay sometimes people
don't believe
and
it um kind of
it's kind of written like a sermon like
because
it was such a flashback for me it's like
i could see him
because of his writing style and the the
words and the principles that he's
sharing and like reading scripture it's
like
it was like i was back in church
hearing him
he writes like he talks
like he preaches i i kind of inferred
and it was
um i just noticed that i just started to
feel like
kind of sick
and
it
it it didn't get i didn't get any
insight into it besides the fact that
like
realized that it was actually triggering
like
i mean you know you
you hear the term and you throw it
around
a lot
honestly
you know i've always felt like you know
i'm i'm i'm not a person to be triggered
you know it's like i'm i'm ashamed to
admit that i've always thought that that
word applies to other people
um
you've really got to be you've got to
have you've got to have some sort of
specific
trauma in order for that to happen
and
i i i just don't go to i don't go to
church i don't like to listen to sermons
anymore and i don't read the bible
anymore so i kind of have have stayed
away from that
like
kind of crossing the threshold of a
church in any any form and any sensation
so to find myself there by reading this
it was also a surprise to me
that
you know it just kind of felt like
i mean the specifics of the of the
chapter were
you know it was kind of like this more
the straw man
deconstruction
and it was just an oversimplification
and
left and right it was a dismissal
that i you know
and because i felt like they were
talking about
some they they really weren't talking to
someone who doesn't believe they were
talking to people who
might
who might stop believing which is the
whole point of the book or really he
started talking to people who were
frustrated and beating themselves up
because their evangelism wasn't
effective enough that's actually what a
lot of the chapter ended up being about
and that was a that was a big flashback
to when you know with all of our
training
uh in evangelism
it was just
heaps and heaps of obligation that then
became
shame whenever we couldn't seal the deal
or
go out on the beach and save some
stranger you know even though you know
you do everything you can and you leave
the results to god like we always taught
that but again it just reminded me and
almost like a physical
sense of that feeling of
uh
not being good enough you know not ever
being able to
to cut it to live up to it you didn't
fully embrace the reformed tradition
that you were a part of
and then if you had you would have been
like i do my part and then god
does the important part yeah that's all
i can do i would say that i believed
that and that
i did believe that so i guess so i so i
guess i i didn't have as much strife
about it because i'd be like well if god
doesn't regenerate this person then
you know that's
god's issue
ultimately that's where he goes in this
chapter is talking about how it's a it's
a spiritual response that can
a conversion is a spiritual response
that can only be
um
[Music]
it originates with god
so
if you don't
if if someone that you care about or a
stranger on the beach or anyone in
between doesn't respond
and they just don't believe it's well
some people just don't believe
because
they're not chosen by god to believe
because if god really wants
because he ends up describing the way
that he ends it is you know if you're
really concerned that you might not have
a saving faith this is how the whole
chapter ends it's like well if you're
concerned about it that means that god
has made you concerned about it so you
don't need to be concerned about it
anymore you're definitely safe that's a
sign that you're safe you know i
actually never struggled with
like was i actually saved because i felt
like struggling with that
meant my faith was not
strong enough
so i would never admit to myself that i
ever questioned whether i was saved
because
a strong faith would never do that
you know so it was just my way of
thinking and the way that i interacted
with the whole system
you know it's like i'm i feel like i'm
willing to admit and every time i talk
about this i kind of go back to this
point of like
yeah a lot of what i brought to the
table like my experience my genetics my
environment everything
about my past uh
builds me to react to the the this
evangelical system in a way that
regardless of how much you talk about
grace and love i'm still gonna beat
myself up that's just a fact of the
matter that's exactly how it went
um and then it was just a reminder that
like this totally brought it all back
and kind of triggered all that well you
know one of the things that makes that
difficult for
because you know my wife is uh she's a
different personality than you but but
we relating a lot in this way but she is
as we've talked you know
she suffers from obsessive-compulsive
disorder and specifically scrupulous
scrupulosity which is a type of ocd in
which
if you're a religious person a person of
faith you can kind of turn it into
overdrive where you're basically trying
to be the best possible christian that
you that you can be
and it's interesting when you're in a uh
especially you know she was raised and
you know you may not be washing your
hands
uh she kind of does that she does that a
little bit you're kind of you feel like
you got to wash your spirit yeah your
conscience and
you know she went to a a baptist
christian school where they said things
like if you're 99.9 sure that you're
saved you're 100 lost now they would
never have said that at a reformed
institution which we ended up kind of
going to essentially a reformed church
right
and so that helped somewhat
but the thing is is that the bible and
also just christian teaching and
christian culture in general
the the the idea of grace through faith
and it being a gift from god and this
being basically 100 percent god's
responsibility and you're just basically
responding you're actually you're not
if you're truly reformed you're not even
responding your response is determined
by god
um
it actually doesn't quite jibe with the
idea of all the responsibilities because
if you just look at what jesus had to
say jesus is talking about a lot of
stuff that we should be doing you know
not everybody who says lord lord is will
be saved but only who do the will of my
father
the reformed tradition takes that and
says oh this means it's not about works
when another way to read that is jesus
saying no actually it kind of what you
do is sort of important
so and so you you what regardless of
your theology your personality is going
to latch on to the obligation and the
shame that sort of permeates the whole
way of thinking and by the way there's a
there's at least part of what i'm saying
that is kind of like you know what it's
my fault
and so i hear myself saying that and i'm
like i don't you know what i don't know
if i want to
just accept that
so you know i because i don't i'm not
comfortable like placing blame and like
talking bad about anybody or the church
and you know
coming after anybody when my tendency
always
is to say
okay yeah this is this is on me
this is on me
um
and
these are the things that i'm
deconstructing and a lot of it is belief
by belief like very early on
it was
deconstructing the belief that if if i
left the church
even if christie didn't
our marriage would not survive i've
already talked about that right
um
but you know recently
i've
the the
the teaching has been ringing in my ears
that where jesus said it's easier for a
camel to go through the eye of a needle
than for what
a rich man a rich man entered the
kingdom to enter the kingdom of heaven
because i you know on the last episode
oh you're rich are you on the forbes
list i'm on the forge list are you above
or below ryan the nine-year-old i'm
below him okay but you might be ten now
right though i think we're above him now
but there's another kid above us oh crap
yeah it's probably i think he's a
younger girl
how easy is it for a rich kid to enter
the kingdom of god uh a kid can go
through the eye of a needle because
you're better easier than a camera the
older you get though the bigger you get
typically yeah unless you're benjamin
button gentlemen button can get right
through that damn needle
eventually yeah it takes a while though
you talked about privilege that the
privilege that that we have
uh and so when i say think last week so
when i say things like i'm happy
and you're rich and it's like well
is it because i'm rich and i have am i
blinded to
like because i i believed that yeah what
i believe the teaching is like if you're
rich
you got you think you've got everything
you want
so
you're missing out on what you really
need
not only salvation but like and
like an active
dynamic relationship with god through
jesus
that's what that's what we were taught
to believe
and
so i found myself even wrestling with
that over the past couple of weeks that
like is the am am i lying to myself just
because i'm well off
that is it easy for me to be happy
for that reason um
so
it's a it's a belief that's always been
there then i have to like i have to pick
up and i have to look at and i have to
dismantle it
or
see if maybe i'm wrong about it
you know because i hear that voice
saying
my former self
you know
okay maybe it's not my former self maybe
it's jesus maybe it's the jesus that i
had a relationship with that's what i
always heard from him
you know it's kind of like you you don't
hear the thousands of positive comments
you only hear the negative one it's it's
a human tendency um
do we
even in this
even in this chapter
he talked about
something else that kind of
i guess
triggered
this again
uh when jesus telling is telling the
story of the rich man
who's burning in hell
okay this is luke 16
if you're following along in your
rhet study bible
luke 16 19-31
so the rich man's burning in hell
but he's looking across the chasm at
abraham
and he's able to talk to him is he in
the bosom uh bosom's not mentioned here
the rich man said
then i beg you father talking to abraham
to send
uh to send him uh
you know talking about lazarus like
another guy who's
send him to my father's house where i
got five brothers who are living
so that he may warn them lest they also
come into this place of torment
it's like i got five brothers just raise
him from the dead sit send him over
there
tell him that like i'm burning in hell
they don't need to come here
this is the rich man
you see what i'm saying
and he said
uh but abraham said they have moses and
the prophets let them hear them so they
they have all the truth they need
um
and he said no
if someone goes to them from the dead
they will repent they'll change their
mind and he and then he said abraham
said if they do not hear moses and the
prophets neither will they be convinced
if someone should rise from the dead of
course this is jesus talking referring
to himself
so it's
you know and it's
it's
the first thing that i feel
even reading this two days ago is still
all of that all that teaching just wells
up inside of me that's like
yeah you're gonna be burning in hell you
don't even believe in hell but you're
gonna be burning in it one day and
you're gonna because you're
because you're a rich dude you lied to
yourself
it's like
i don't i don't lay awake at night
thinking these things
but
that's why i'm saying i was triggered in
so many ways because it brings up all
these things that like
uh
these lies
you think about
the whole idea of being rich
right it's like we actually can quantify
how wealth
directly influences happiness because
not from a spiritual standpoint or not
from reading the bible
but from science right like
they've actually done a lot of research
on this
and they have found that up to a certain
point yes more money does bring you more
happiness but above a certain point
right
it it levels out and most people have
and most people
have the ability or regardless of the
circumstances they have a baseline of
happiness that they return to once their
circumstances sort of level out once a
transitional period sort of stops
happening right
and so the fact is is that you know what
the fact that you and i don't have to
worry about is there going to be enough
money
uh that is a a thing that took up a lot
of space in our mind for most of our 20s
when we were on staff with crusade and
we're raising support we're asking
people for money we're getting to places
where it's like
am i gonna have to ask my family for
money in order to pay the grocery bill
like we were in that place for a long
time right and for me that your whole
childhood that fear goes goes much
deeper in into my psyche too yeah yeah
so you're not ever going to get to feel
to feel relief
by not having to worry
about money in the same way
is like something that then i've i'm
like should i feel guilty for this it's
a knee jerk reaction yeah but
but the point i'm really making is that
yeah
you probably are
feeling a little bit of relief and
happiness because of your financial
situation but you know what like there's
another end of that when you get to a
certain place where all of a sudden
finances become sure a burden in a
different way because you're helping
people out and you're trying to figure
out what to do with it whatever
and i'm not saying that i am happy
because i'm rich i'm not saying that
yeah i understand that uh but but what
i'm saying is that
but i get scared that there's an element
of it that's just a natural phenomenon
based on the way the human mind works
and so you don't ne so you don't
necessarily have to go beyond that to
over spiritualize that particular aspect
of your life is what was what i'm
getting yeah so it's like to actually to
experience relief
and
happiness
and then for it to immediately be
undercut with
guilt
and shame
is a product of
a lot of things including
the teaching that i was
steeped in
my entire life and that yeah so i am
deconstructing i mean the other thing
those things
the other thing is
i mean
coming out of the pandemic and the
specific challenges that
that we went through as a family
uh
i am experiencing the relief of things
leveling out we're in a period where
things are you know
we're not devoid of personal challenges
don't get me wrong and you you know that
um
but it's
they're of a different flavor and it's
kind of like it's settled down so it's
not a spike it's it's a little bit more
of a valley so it's like it is a kind of
a it's a time when i can take a breath
so i'm on this trip but i'm taking more
of a breath and that's also a reason why
i'm
i'm realizing that i'm happier
because i'm at this season of life or
this little phase where
uh you know maybe there's another storm
around the corner but i'm not
i'm not in a downpour
um
but again for that to be undercut is is
telling
um
another thing and i'll segue into like
therapy update here which is another
huge part of my uh spiritual journey
right now is
um i guess the last time at this table
we talked about therapy we were talking
about how
i
i basically came to the conclusion that
i needed to switch therapists i needed
to find a new therapist
well i did um with the help of christy
with the help of christy's therapist and
um
you know the the conversation we had
then and then subsequent conversations
uh
that you and i had it was like very
helpful to kind of get me
to really get me to to work on that and
christy did a lot of work
she was like okay it's the top of the
year you're gonna you're gonna go for
this you're not gonna you're not gonna
languish or be in this limbo it could be
six months if you don't
if you don't just meet with somebody it
may not be the right person
and um so i've been meeting with a
therapist new therapist for
actually tonight will i think will be
our sixth meeting
um
and
it's going really good
like it's and it's totally different
than therapy was
uh before and a lot of that is like with
everything that i was going through and
all of the uh acute issues
that
like a bunch of fires that needed to be
put out there were a bunch of torrential
downpours i'm mixing metaphors here
but
well a lot of pores can put out fires
but you want rain when the when it's the
wildfire season comes around but then it
turns into a mudslide and like it like
destroys your entire home you can't get
away that's what it felt like for a
while
one thing's going to help no it's going
to make things worse kind of a thing but
and so therapy was really helpful
but it was more of that like acute
survival
get through it as i think i talked about
last time
but now i was able to set the stage with
this new therapist to say you know what
i'm
i want to move into a new phase
these are the things and i kind of like
shared some of the
complaints i had with how
my frustrations with therapy
before and saying hey it was only my
first therapist
this is what i'm looking for if this
isn't you let me know so like on our
first phone call like the pre-interview
thing like i kind of just
laid all that out there and i'm glad i
did
because
he was able to respond and say okay well
i'm different in this way you're you
want you want something that's more
conversational i hear you saying you
want something that feels a little more
relational
um
and but then he also talked about
that
his therapeutic approach and how it was
different and i talked about my
spiritual background
and he had
a specific point of view on that he had
experience with that
like he had a point of reference for the
evangelical church
and
um
dealing with
shame
like that was something that he spent a
lot of time with so i was like okay yeah
this is this could really
work especially because i've said that i
want to go deeper i want to start
tackling these issues
and so that's i think a lot of the
conversation that i'm having here
it sounds like i'm just being hit with
stuff like when driving my van or when
i'm reading this and being triggered
but i i do think i'm
able to talk about it make more sense of
it just based on the last
five sessions the first five sessions
i've had in therapy because it's been
much more pointed
in in that direction of relating it to
my
my experience in the church and my
deconstruction
continual deconstruction
like when i talk about the the
the camel going through the eye of the
needle that's something that i that came
up in therapy
that like surprised me
but it was just an and there was a
realization that that's another that's
like wow i'm re i am really still just
deconstructing because i kind of put a
pause on that
for
uh
almost the past two years
in a lot of ways
um at least like appointed i'm to dig
into my past
in different ways and then really see
what
what applications are there how i can
grow
and what lessons i can learn
so
that's i'm really encouraged you know
and one and one thing real quick there
too i
we didn't talk about with the the the
eye of the needle thing
yeah um
is
which i'd be willing to guess jesus did
say uh and i'm not saying jesus only
says the things that you want him to say
another there's there's more to it than
that
but you know when jesus taught about the
kingdom of heaven
uh
most of the time or all of the time it
seemed like he was talking about
something that was present
right that was present now that was
present on earth that he was inviting
you into something right he was inviting
in you inviting you into a new way of
thinking a new way of living
and
and i think that the point to that story
which i
to that parable
or the saying or whatever it is i
completely i think both of us would
agree it's like
money
is a is a distraction right and it can
be something that makes it more
difficult for you to be present and
enter into
life in a meaningful
fruitful way
because our natural instinct is to
collect and hoard and get worried about
that and protect that and it's not a
very spiritual mindset that's not a
christian idea that's a sort of broadly
spiritual idea that you're going to find
in islam you're going to find in
buddhism you're going to find a hinduism
this idea that money
can be a distraction to those things
right and so again the old
evangelical voice we always read that as
riches are going to make it difficult to
enter the kingdom of heaven heaven being
the afterlife and not that oh a rich man
doesn't get in but like somebody who's
putting their riches over their
relationship with jesus or you know what
i'm saying but it
you can
there is a way to approach that
with a with a free mindset where you can
actually take what the the wisdom that's
there without
letting the guilt seep in yeah shame
seeping you know i'll give a different
example so we're not just harping on the
rich
since i was so close to the end of this
book i skipped the last chapter
uh
which is
the one about jesus maybe that's the one
that would have changed everything for
me but i skipped it
and then it was just ads for other books
that the gospel coalition had oh nice
and they got like the picture of the
book is called taming the tongue what
the [ __ ] is that about
how the gospel transforms our talk by
jeff robinson and then uh nancy guthrie
who's an author and bible teacher gave
an endorsement
and it you know there's no cursing in
her endorsement i don't think so this
book hit home with me perhaps and just
she's just she describes her experience
reading this book this is a
endorsement in the back of
this book okay
well
listen you got to take every
advantage i mean let me know about ads
oh yeah listen to her experience though
and it's
see if it's like mine
this book hit home with me perhaps
because some of my greatest regrets
have come from ways i've misused words
confidences i didn't keep
criticism i was too eager to offer
bragging to make myself seem important
dominating the conversation when i
should have listened
i've also misused words by keeping
silent when i should have come clean
when i should have offered praise when i
should have spoken up
these and many more insights
on how
i am
these and many more insights on how we
use our words are covered in this brief
but wisdom-filled book a great book to
read prayerfully on your own but even
better to use to discuss with a small
group so you can air out how
you are
in a small group setting
you know it's
why you know it's like this is the stuff
that i would eat up it's like oh yeah
yeah now okay now i gotta tame the
tongue yeah it's like oh okay you know
i'm doing all these things
uh i'm criticizing i'm bragging i'm oh
[ __ ] i'm also not saying things i'm
keeping silent when i should come clean
i should be offering praise
you know
i just i'm so glad
that i don't have to read any more of
that book
you know i'm so glad
are you saying that
those ideas are not important are you
saying that
i'm saying that i know you're not i'm
playing devil's advocate here i just
want to i want to know what
because one way of interpreting what
you're saying is it's eviscerated you
can just do whatever you want to and you
don't need to
yeah you don't have to follow any rules
uh
that's not my problem
right that's not my problem exactly
my problem
is
being eviscerated by rules
and
i it turns out
i'm
a pretty good person
but
i have to convince myself of that
very frequently
and that i think that's sad
uh but i think that's my work
you know it's not
because it because i believe that it's
true not because i it will make me
happier
uh i and i feel like everything that
i've said today will just it can anybody
who wants to from the inside
where we used to be like you said you
would have written chapters in that book
and i would have written off everything
that i've said and everything that i've
said last year and the year before
because
that's how i was
but i was
i would do it
to others because i did it to myself
twice as much
and i would get mad that other people
weren't doing that to themselves
you know and it's
it was
it was not a good way
it was not a
it was not a good life to live
for me it was not i was i wasn't
thriving
well this is one of the things that
people are different right and i think
that
and this has probably gotten better we
haven't been a part of the church for a
while but one of the things that we
noticed especially in college is that
uh the only distinction that was made
between people was men and women right
it was like okay there's a the men are
going to separate and go into this room
and talk about a few things and then
women are going to go in this room
they're going to talk about a few things
and we'll talk about some stuff together
but like that was the one distinction
but there was very little nuance
discussed about people's personalities
kind of what you're getting at is the
fact that
um
whether you call it enneagram one or
whether you just call it a person who
struggles with shame and guilt
and my wife
in a different way struggles with it
we have to be sensitive
you know if i was still in the church
what i would be saying is we got to be
sensitive to those people who are
natural rule followers and are naturally
self-critical and we don't need to spend
a lot of time getting them to understand
what the right and the wrong is because
it's so built into who they are we need
to be really pouring grace into their
lives right whereas you got somebody
like me
that's you know i kind of need rules
right
because my tendency is to just decide
that they don't apply to me
you know what i'm saying and so when i
read her say that
her her review of that book and i and i
see
i'm like yeah i kind of that's true
i
need to think about the way that i speak
i need to think about the impact that my
words have i need to think about the
impact that the lack of my words have
right
and those are principles that i can
apply to myself without a sense of guilt
or shame just because i'm like yeah
that's true and i need to do that and i
don't do that on a regular basis
i don't think there was room for that
uh for us
for us to sort of i mean i didn't
experience that to see things
differently um
another update that i'm
totally
fine to share i think at a certain point
i'm i didn't know if i was going to be
but
um i've started anxiety medication
yes
so that's why you're happy
right so it's like okay just uh
that that was also at the top of the
year uh you know under my doctor's care
also talking uh with with my therapist
but um
yeah i started taking zoloft
well
sertraline
i think he's like the cheaper generic
generic
uh i thought you were rich why can't you
get the real stuff
it's great it's the exact same i'm
taking 25 milligrams i i took that for a
month and
um
i knew i had a bunch of negative
side effects that i expected headaches
every day
uh some nausea i would take it in the
morning
because that's when i i take my other
supplements in my smoothie if i took it
at night i would forget it wasn't that
bad except for one day i got a migraine
you remember that
well my wife was you know who's also
medicated
in this way uh
she
was talking to you
she wanted me to take it at night she
and she she told me the story she was
like you know i told link that the same
thing happened to me and i just switched
it tonight and he was like oh no no i
can't do that i have to do it when i do
it i have to do it in the morning like
yeah that's when i want to take it don't
change this routine i would rather be
nauseous and have headaches just that's
awesome
because once i get over it that's when i
need to take it consistently
and um
[Music]
going on reddit like
whatever you're experiencing in your
life uh you know it's
go on reddit and search it just to have
other people who
i'm i mean this is kind of a
i think there's danger in this advice
again in general trigger warning when
you send people to reddit
i mean i go to the i went to the zoloft
thread and it was just really helpful to
hear people oh yeah anecdotal
uh
accounts if you want to get the unbiased
opinion about people's experience with
things a lot of times you get the right
reddit thread and it will be very
helpful yeah you got to find the right
one and you can't you that that's not
going above my doctor's care
but it's all very practical stuff and
like you you hear like the
the preponderance of evidence that a lot
of people have headaches so i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna get freaked out about that
um
and then i've also noticed that uh it
takes longer to climax and i'm i'm
talking about sexually
like get to the top of a mountain on a
hike yeah
it doesn't affect hiking but that's not
a bad thing no that's a good thing it's
a good thing because it's it's just uh
more pleasure
for a longer time double your pleasure
double your fun double my dose to uh 50
milligrams as of yesterday because
uh i want to have sex even longer no i'm
joking
uh
for me to get
just the part of it that helps with that
uh
yeah i think you just shave off the end
of the pill oh gosh i thought you're
gonna shave off
i was like i'm circumcised already
and i don't think that helps um
the reason why i up my dose is because
uh all the all the side effects
basically subsided after three weeks but
then
it's it's still kind of hard to tell if
my because for me it's not i don't have
panic attacks
i've never had a panic attack
i've actually been in denial that i've
had and i spoke about this in the last
therapy uh update
i've been in denial that i've had like a
diagnosable anxiety disorder
but i said okay
my last therapist said i did uh
i mean when you're having heart
palpitations
that they're not constant but they come
and go it's like i've had that for
decades
whenever
my
stress would get over a certain
threshold
uh so that would i mean so i was like
that's gone
that's what went away
after you're not getting the warnings on
your watch that say after a couple of
weeks
evaded heart rate
well palpitation is different it's just
like a flutter it's not an ele it it
wouldn't show up as an elevated heart
rate
but um and sometimes like i remember
when i worked for ibm i would lay down
on the couch to watch television and
that's when i'd feel it when you get
still
they're happening but you only feel it
when you feel it when you're still or
sometimes they'll wake you up when
you're sleeping
um
but those have gone away but i don't
i think i might be able to benefit from
upping the dose so i'm i'm seeing
if there's more benefit there because
that's really the only thing i can point
to
and it's really you know it
it hasn't been
it really takes a couple of months for
you to really see
so
um
yeah i mean it it took
i had to get over this
hump of
uh
being willing to say that i have a
problem that i might need
medication for it was it was you know
with christy and jesse speaking so
openly about it
for for years and the benefits of it i
was very
you know i had a very positive
outlook on it but i was just like you
know but i don't need it
i don't need it i just
you know
my i just
am constantly eviscerating myself in my
own brain
but that's just that's just my normal
you know so
it
it took
everything kind of coming together
uh
to to get to this point
but once i got over it i'm like okay i
i'm when i started having headaches
it did i actually didn't question it
because i feel like this is it's just an
experiment
and it'll either work or it won't but
i'm not going to quit before i find out
if it works and it has already started
to work
uh but like i do have a little bit of a
headache right now
and i kind of hate you no i don't i'm
i'm not irritable but i might be later
don't take it personally
i won't i guess so that's where this is
ending it really all comes down to drugs
like that's my spiritual journey right
now well
hand me the the book because i because i
i'm thinking of i'm thinking of a
chapter that i read as you talk about
these things again
you know but i do feel like i'm i've
just lobbed all these softballs that
anybody who cares to
uh just write me off
but but i don't care i don't care and
the
the reality is they don't because it's
not about some belief
some belief that they can
counterpoint that then they can use to
keep people they love from leaving the
faith and that's why they come after you
well
the ironic thing
is um
i
i don't know i'm
i try a lot of things out on this
podcast just new thoughts so
um
but one of the things that's hitting me
is uh you know we were from the reform
perspective uh the a lot of the
christians that we're still in very
close relationship with or in the
reformed tradition like we haven't
written christians often in our lives
um
and still taught regularly to many
um
and i do think that
for those who are truly reformed
like sort of like
all the way to
you know full tulip calvinists yeah um
i know that they're worried about us but
then i think that they have the ability
to kind of farm it out to well if
they're not chosen they're not chosen
and i have to deal with that but it's
not like i can say much to change them
at this point
i think the way that i'm beginning to
think about
in convincing people and that kind of
thing again i have this i want to
convince people of things
but you start realizing that
no one ever has been ever no one's ever
been forced into believing something
like believing something is a sort of an
involuntary reaction to a set of
circumstances and experiences and
predispositions
you get to this place and you just you
either do believe that something is true
or you don't believe that something is
true now new information can be given to
you that might make you reconsider it
but
just the idea that i can say something
that's going to fundamentally change the
way somebody thinks about something like
i'm actually moving more into that place
not from a reform perspective because i
don't believe in that but just from um
don't worry too much about it like when
you talk about oh i've said all this
stuff that could be used against me i
know you're not really worrying about it
but yeah i don't think
but you know we'll read any of that or i
have you know i've seen the the
the posts and the in the comments and
the reposts and the sound bites and all
that stuff and you know my
mind has changed about those things over
time to a place that's like well of
course that's what you're going to say
right
but
as you talk about therapy and you talk
about
medication
you know i'm reminded of chapter two in
this book
which i think was the most relatable for
me from ian harbour
because
ian went through a deconstruction and
went and moved to basically progressive
christianity okay uh he mentions our
friend uh science mike oh he does what's
the title of the
chapter
progressive christianity was even
shallower than the evangelical faith i
left right and so it was this idea of
like my faith was deconstructed and i
moved into progressive christianity and
what i found is that
they weren't giving me anything to build
to rebuild a faith
and also it was characterized by a lot
of rigid fundamentalist thinking
group think and that was stuff that i
was uncomfortable with in the original
thing that i left yeah
i find it interesting that the
application was to go back to the
original faith
versus just saying i don't want to
identify with an ideology or a
groupthink but
progressives had become just as
fundamentalists as the fundamentalists
that they despised only now instead of
the litmus test being traditional values
it was wokeness if you didn't toe the
party line of progressive orthodoxy you
were an outcast a heretic
i'd heard about the dangers of
moralistic therapeutic deism mtd the
default american religion in which god
simply wants you to live a decent life
not be sad and he doesn't intrude on
your life
i originally ran to progressive
christianity to counter that kind of
shallow belief but when i but what i
found was more of the same only with new
definitions wokeness was the new
morality therapy was the new path to
happiness cancel culture was the new
church discipline and like mtd there was
conveniently no personal god to place
demands on your life in any meaningful
way and this progressive mtd elizabeth
gilbert's trope is the only thing left
god dwells within you as you there's no
way to distinguish between ourselves and
god in this paradigm we are god
um he goes on to talk about he's not
anti-wokeness or anti-therapy he
was in therapy for a couple years in
college can it benefit many of us
but i think that therapy is the path to
happiness
well uh
maybe
maybe i would say that
okay you've taken this opportunity to
give your
spiritual update
which kind of
becomes also a therapy update so how do
you respond to that
um is therapy your religion
definitely
um
i see therapy as my
i need therapy to help me make sense of
all this
you know
it i'm talking about i've talked for
over an hour
and i'm just scratching the surface of
insight into myself this is the work
that i'm doing
is to
to understand
my past my present so that then i can
move into my future
um
unburdened from
from
unnecessary burdens
uh
and be the
be the to love you know i'm gonna go
back to that i mean that is my goal
but
i need professional help to understand
myself and to break down
the lies that i've been telling myself
so that i will be free to be
the best me i can be you know insert
whatever trope you want at that point
you know um i i think that this is a
path forward
uh
it is not it's not a religion it's not
something that i worship it's not a
system of
beliefs
or uh
actions
it's uh
it's help it's um it's treatment
in a lot of ways that then opens me up
to
where i can go next on my
life journey and spiritual journey but i
feel like i'm very much i everything
that i've described today
is
i i feel like i'm being
i'm being held back from not fully
processing my past
and
this is my treatment to
to process it so that
i can continue to move forward to be
you know
i want to be open
i want to be
i want to have a vibrant experience i
want to live life to the fullest and i
want to make the
the most positive impact i can make
in
on while i'm here
uh
and i think that i think this is a
necessary
step of treatment for me
uh
i could i guess i could imagine that
some people would just worship therapy
as a religion but i
um
i just see it a lot simpler than that
i mean the thing that i would say to
a guy like ian is
i think we're all on a on a journey
toward wholeness
well if we're if we're getting healthier
if we're seeking
things that will
be a benefit i don't want to be on a
journey to wholeness
yeah right right you know when it's like
okay i've got it figured out or this is
you know when it's when it's negative
this negative that i'm against this i'm
against that and so i i mean i hear what
he's saying when it's like if you just
move from being against a bunch of to
being a bunch again against a bunch of
other
you know it's like
i'm so some people get off on that but
that's just not me so i guess i agree
with
i feel that well i mean i definitely
agree with the idea that you know
fundamentalist thinking happens in
multiple circles right we talked about
that last time and i'm very
uncomfortable with a lot of the
fundamentalist thinking that i see on
the left i am you know uh because i
think there's not a lot of room for
people ask questions without being
labeled and right and there's a very
binary way of approaching a lot of
things
but
and obviously i believe that exists on
the right and it was one of the things
that i was happy to leave behind not the
reason i deconstructed but just
something i was happily i was happy to
leave behind
but if we're all trying to move towards
wholeness and we're all trying to make
sense like you say make sense of your
experience make sense of your life and
ultimately i don't want to i don't want
to say it's about a pursuit of happiness
because that's a little too shallow
because i think that happiness is just a
state of being that comes and goes and
you can't you can't achieve some
personnel we used to talk about joy
being much more important than happiness
as christians right
um
i think for
for ian
in his
journey toward wholeness
for whatever reason because of his
personality makeup his circumstances his
background
having
tying into some kind of traditional
system and an idea that there is a
more well-defined source of this
authority and this purpose is something
that
he's after
uh and it might be something that is at
least for right now required in his in
his journey toward wholeness
i'm not gonna blame him for that again i
can't change the you know he he
deconstructed he got into what he calls
progressive christianity
and then saw some emptiness there and is
going back to something that feels more
well defined or just fits
his particular
disposition better
and i i think that that's the thing that
i'm trying to
like but that's not what you're after
that's not what i'm after but we're also
not after the same thing right yeah and
so to go back to your randy travis of it
all
whereas maybe if i was in that van
coming down
you know the highway
yeah i'd listen to some randy travis if
i'm not gonna listen to randy travis the
whole time i'm gonna put on this
book about some other thing that i'm
interested in
and that's my moving towards wholeness
that and that's actually following my
intuition and and in that case it's
following my desire that my intuition
tells me is good for me right
versus like i'm gonna do something
that's gonna tear down me and tear down
my relationships and right right
and to me and this sounds
you know whatever whatever
that's spirituality broadly defined
um
it doesn't have to have it doesn't have
to be super well defined
because i'm not able to define it well
and that's not something i'm after and i
don't think it's something that you're
after yeah right but if that's something
that you are after you you are going to
gravitate towards orthodox systems
and you know what maybe that's what's
best for you at this point and i'm not
going to try to convince you otherwise
yeah
okay well we'll end it there i think um
it was
i've got some more bones to dig up
i'm going to be digging up bones for a
while you know that's a randy travis
reference i know you're catching that
but i i will leave you with a wreck
and um you know uh and i'm gonna stay
in
in a
an audio book that i've been listening
to
uh
miracle and wonder this has been very
spiritually edifying for me
um
it it looks at jesus from you know what
he doesn't look at jesus at all it's
about paul simon
i got you
uh
audible book miracle and wonder
conversations with paul simon and
malcolm gladwell
and uh
five hours long
and it's
you know it's the malcolm gladwell
treatment of paul simon one of the
greatest songwriters of all time so you
really get an insight into his creative
process
so it's not as much personal as it's a
it's a it's a study in creativity and
songwriting through candid conversations
uh
like
50 hours of conversations that that 30
hours of conversation that he recorded
um being in the same room with him
uh so it's it's really cool especially
the first half
if you're a fan of
uh paul simon and uh
simon and garfunkel as well it's like
it's it's very
inspiring and uh
from a creative standpoint spiritually
edifying
so
check it out highly recommend it miracle
and wonder
well thanks for listening to our updates
um
hashtag earbiscuits let us know
where you're at you know we we we love
to hear
we love for you to take part in the
conversation you hear where you're at
how you're processing these things
we're interested in your ideas
and your experiences so share them with
us if you if you're willing how did you
process this
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]